[Music]
what we want to do today was we've got a
call
that we'll get to here in a little bit
but i wanted to back out and just walk
folks through
my thought process and how i've lived
some of this out of my own life
and really man i've just worked with
hundreds of people
thousands probably on their trauma
on the bricks in the backpack what how
do they get to a place where they can
make the next right decision
right so here's here's me backing all
the way out
in high school i think i was a freshman
um there was this big camp summer camp
that i went to every year
and at this summer camp there was a
talent show and there's probably a
thousand kids at this camp
and then you had adults in campus so put
yourself in this auditorium it's
completely packed it's not like a school
cafeteria auditorium but it's a big
giant auditorium
and um lights the sound system the whole
thing and i'm sitting up on a chair
and i s sang a song that i wrote
and it was just a silly song about i
don't know
dating and girls and whatever so i sing
this song it's a big
hit and everything goes great and a big
the big selling point was i wrote this
song
right i didn't
what actually happened was a couple
weeks before camp
there was this live recording that i had
heard it was like a bootleg
of a pearl jam concert and i was
listening to it with a couple of
my buddies who were in my high school
rock band we were incredible by the way
and we were not but we were awesome and
so
we were listening to this it was awesome
we talked back and forth and
they played this new song and i just
remembered how
catchy the hook of this song was the
chorus was and
at that point i've been playing guitar
for a long time and you can you can pick
a chord progression out of the air
and you just learn the melodies real
quick and
so i took this really catchy chorus
and i attached it to some cheesy words
and i told everybody i wrote this song
it was all well and good until those
idiots in pearl jam decided to quote
unquote
release the song in the fall
suddenly i got letters as a 14 year old
from all over the country
about wow you're a writer for pearl jam
how cool how'd you get that gig
how did they find out about your song
that you sing
at church camp how how did that happen
that's so great and then one guy just
wrote a letter
and he just said dude i think you're a
liar
and he was pretty much hit the nail on
the head there right so i was 14
and straight up busted so next year i go
back to this church camp and it's kind
of the buzz
like wow dude what a what a loser
um and then you got to come up with i
came up with all these excuses and tried
to wiggle my way out of it right but
it was a mess and if i back up before
that
um in fourth grade i was playing tag
with a girl i had a crush on
um am i like can i say their name
we had there's a lot of people listen to
this now we have far exceeded our
our 19 listeners um so there's this girl
and fourth grader her name was ron i
won't say her last name but man i was in
love with her
and we were playing tag or something
after school in the cafeteria and i was
so what you do when you like somebody in
your fourth grade right is you play tag
and you
push and shove and be silly and anyway
man
we were i was sprinting after her and
she
made a turn or started to make a turn
right by the wall and i went to
to tag her and i pushed her a little bit
and i tell you what uh i remember
i've seen a lot of trauma just worked
with a lot of traumatic
crisis situations i remember her scream
as she was smashed up against that wall
she broke both wrists
in that and um i
that's her scream is lodged into my soul
i remember it i'll never
forget it and for weeks i guess months
afterwards she
had both arms were in a cast and
it turned into this we're just playing
having fun and it got real serious real
fast right
um another one in in high school my
senior year my
i dropped the baton in i was the anchor
of the mile relay
in the district track meet and we lost
by one point
and um that was the first loss in 10
years
i was about to do the decade sweep and i
dropped it and that's that's
still to this day right so even
thinking up to like a few weeks ago a
few months ago my son
it was just hey dad hey dad hey dad hey
dad and i was doing something trying to
fix the mower some dead thing and hey
dad hey daddy dad and i finally just
turned and said
what well you just stop for a second
right so i was loud
and then he his eyes get big because i
don't usually raise my voice and i don't
usually snap like that and
he backed up and said hey sorry sorry
dad sorry dad and then of course i was
like man what an
idiot to myself right so i
i tell you those those stories right
because my life's been this circus of
bad decisions and crazy situations and
wild stories
and that doesn't include i mean that's
the ones we can tell on the
podcast right the ones that the statute
of limitations is running out on
um but there was times you know i lied
about stuff and stole things and didn't
have discipline i cut corners and blamed
other people
man i used to lie and steal all the time
as a kid it's one of those things that
haunts me as an adult
um and then there was times that i came
through in the clutch and turned my life
around and then times i didn't come
through the clutch right so it's
when times when you get the big job and
then times when you don't get the big
job
and it goes to somebody else and you
quit a job and you wish you could have
that job back and
we all have these stories right it's
childhood mayhem and accidents
and then it goes to things your dad said
that still rattle around in your head
right or the way
like after the first time you kiss
somebody and you back up and you look at
him in the eyes
and you know that was a terrible kiss
or or you look in the eye and think
that like that was incredible right or
the first time your mom
slammed the cabinets in in anger or
first time you were abused by someone
who loved you or the first time you back
your car into something the first time
your
checking account goes into the red right
it's all of these moments
i remember the time i turned in a
multi-million dollar
performer for a residence hall to a
college president
and they had so he told me to put
together a you know uh
amortization schedule for the debt
service against this large residence
hall and so i put together
on a word document and i highlighted
words and i changed the fonts there's
probably some comic sans in there
and i'll never forget handing it to him
in a big fancy meeting
in his face it looked like i just handed
him a plate of diarrhea that's what his
face
looked like just it was like
it wasn't even shame it was like what
what what am i looking at
did you hand me a like a multi-million
dollar performer on a
on a do you write a story is this a poem
and i just remember feeling so ashamed
that i went and hired
a senior in college to come teach me
excel
in like alone i told them this is like a
big secret right
so you have these moments right and
man it all comes back to these stories
right these stories these stories and
they become a part of us
and so when i meet with folks even as
late as this past weekend um there's
a couple came out to work on their
marriage to stand at our house and it
never ceases to amaze me how these
stories especially these ones from
childhood
follow us around they follow us around
forever
right because here's what happened those
stories i told you when you're 14 of
course you tell big stories and i just
happened to be on a stage and
it became a real big one right or
playing
as a as a nine-year-old right these
things happen that's just life
but what we don't often realize is how
long
and i'm talking about i'm
many many many decades later
um that i still carry around this tag
that i'm a liar
right or i still carry around this
notion that
if you screw around a kid is going to
get hurt really really bad and it's
going to be your fault
right i still it's still lodged in there
or when the game is on the line
if delony's fourth leg he's probably
gonna screw something up
right and that is translated into my
marriage into business into parenting
right
and of course you know you snap at your
kid
the logical conclusion is because you
suck at being a dad right you're just a
crappy dad
and these stories hang around and i feel
them in my body
in the present time even though they
haven't happened for years
right i am comically
obnoxiously um i used to steal a lot as
a kid i'll drive an hour out of the way
to take a quarterback
like a like if somebody overpays me i'm
so obnoxious about it now
uh i'm pathological about truth-telling
like i'm
obsessive about it um i
am obsessive about making sure kids have
fun but let's all do it say
it just become a part of us right but
it's these stories we're born into
these stories that we were told these
stories that we tell ourselves and other
people right
and then the actual things that actually
happened right and so
um some of these stories are things
we're born into
poverty right we're born into violence
you're born into abuse you're born into
sexualization you're born into race
culture gender sexuality some of these
things you're born and it's just that
the narrative the air that the culture
around you is breathing
nothing you did or didn't do it just is
what you were launched
into earth with right in into life and
then there's these
um some and some of them are good right
that you are launched in and things are
gonna work out for you you got two
parents who loved you and you are
connected
and you got one parent that loved you
and you've got people sacrificing on
your behalf and
and and people look in your eye and
telling you you're a person of value
you're going to do really great things
one day and we're going to support you
and care for you right so it's whatever
these stories that you were born into
and then you've got these stories that
you were told
right the ones that that you were told
ah man like you would really be
attractive
if your teeth weren't so weird right or
you would be the best looking guy in the
world if you're
you didn't have so much acne if you just
fix your skin oh my gosh it'd be so hot
or or or right and then that's not to
mention the stories that instagram tells
you
about what attraction looks like and how
much sex you should be having and
um that it's viewer abuses
may have been your fault if you had just
not fill in the blank right
and then what happens over time is those
stories
morph into this is where i think it gets
really damning is
those stories that other people tell you
you start telling yourself in your own
voice
and since we always tell the truth to
ourselves right
then it gets hard right then suddenly
you're just that kid in the husky jeans
and you're 45 and you still don't like
what you see in the mirror
right and or you got in a wreck when you
were a kid
and you still can't let go of the wheel
and you're so anxious and tense and
tense and anxious right
and it's story after story about them
and about you and about us and about
tomorrow about yesterday
and some of these stories i like to call
them bricks